the division is coming out this year
fingers crossed
no more slips and Ubisoft brought a
bunch of games last year some of them
were pretty great yes mediocre how what
was your favorite sort of game out of
you know stuff like Assassin's Creed far
cry valiant hearts saw you guard our
hearts and Shadow the light I think
we're the highlights for them last year
but I did that more triple a group I
think Fargo it was a far cry future have
you guys noticed that they have this
sort of last year it's not a
conversation to bed I don't say homogeny
but there's definitely some like
mechanics to keep repeating across there
there their games be it like the
climbing on top of a tower to sink your
points in your points literally that's
in watchdog homes and far crimes and
both Assassin's Creed games as well and
massive influence on co-op as well
especially in like the crew again
there's another game that was like I
would I been happy playing a
single-player but it was like super
co-op focused you're here and have you
guys noticed that at across like all of
their games how do you feel about this
sort of the fact that I have this one I
guess the set of rules that they're
applying to all the different Ranchettes
do you think some of benefit in some of
like sure I mean the big one for me
that's alarming is the coop trend yeah
after we after a three right and every
showed their next-gen games or whatever
I was like okay so this generation is
going to be defined by playing with
other people great and then everything
comes out broken and the servers are
down on Christmas and it's like oh my
god you know I mean like and like you
talk about the division and I'm talking
about evolved and I'm talking about all
these games they're coming up and it's
like crap like you know this is
terrifying yeah I mean I remember when
we talked about you know the division is
so intriguing to me it's a set in New
York which is awesome and very
post-apocalyptic I love the dystopian
kind of stuff I mean that's great but my
biggest question when we heard about the
game was like can I play it by myself
yeah and they eventually said yes but of
course you feel like you're getting less
of an experience when these games seem
to be designed around a cooperative
experience which I've new Toria is like
I don't want to play online like I play
by myself at my own pace these are the
kinds of games where I just want to take
my time and you can't do that with
people chattering your ears and someone
blowing your cover or something like
that so yeah I agree that there is a
there is a homogeneous off games in
terms of formula which I'm sure is
intentional people seem to like it so
yeah did you guys saw one no I mean the
thing with
division that's interesting but sort of
distinguish it from the far cry coop the
Assassin's Creed unity co-op maybe not
so much the crew caught but like it
seems like the coop here is also
dependent on other groups of cooperative
players and coming into your universe
because that was a big reveal at the end
of the trailer they forth they first
showed off at e3 a couple years ago was
oh we're you know we're fighting our way
through here but then there's this other
team here this other team here and those
are not MPC's they're people who are
talking there are people that populate
this world that makes it more dangerous
that makes it more exciting and I think
that's just like doubles down on that
risk reward of online connectivity all
the time co-op oh yeah see the thing
about like Assassin's Creed for instance
was like that's a sort of a
single-player game that they have
allowed a co-op piece of I'm not you
could say is largely the same for a far
cry 4 as well like I can just say I'm on
your own exactly like just say there's
another guy here yeah the main stuff
just go take that outpost but I got but
then the crew was a game that was trying
to like made co-op such an integral part
of it that over Christmas I couldn't
play it right because there's an online
game even though I never do any co-op
without whatsoever hmm my worry I guess
is that with the division it being a
sort of a co-op like centric game that
perhaps like every giver worried that
like a really good when they put all
that time and effort into like I'm
facing this co-op experience into a game
that perhaps that would have been time
spent making like a really good singer
per expanse like I'm probably like
you're like a love thing games like fall
night for 400 hours and that's that's my
big female fall I mean we were just
talking about that was you know fallout
4 i I wonder why don't I prediction
comes prediction and when I protecting
this city 3 comes out this year and I'm
liking when do we get the beta for
multiplayer yeah yeah I mean I I think I
mean what am i doing our new game spot
guess one of the things I said was I
think fallout 4 house in the next couple
months I think that fought for is
they'll have a hands on event they'll
show something in Iggy 3 and every yeah
I said this year like I really believe
that I think that they're like sitting
on it and there's no reason to prolong
the agony from all they kind of my
thought it was gonna be in a two events
this year yeah I was sure possibly III
and I guess the games come as a bit of a
weird one but the MV Jax Awards because
they don't know sure that Skyrim was the
next when I was on Spike right and so
this is like a game that work sort of
there are the little horses about it
like it's definitely a development yeah
and my big fear with that game I
fought three and I Love New Vegas I
think those are both fantastic games and
I'm so afraid that like you can't pull
your naga metal plate in the way that
the design team played the great thing
why they games like I don't know I want
to do and I'm just gonna walk in this
direction and then some like guy is
gonna run by and like you know shoot you
or you're gonna be with some friend
chattering hi there is something there's
there's the sanctity of the
single-player experience is waning and
that's like really bother me I feel like
there will be games that won't do it and
I really think fallout one you're
talking about they understand if
somebody walks buying like tea bags or
radroach and runs up there were two
separate Fallout on lines in development
at one stage sure as well like would I
think that there's the hot one and then
who it was an interplay I think only
licensed in the first place they were
also and it was a bunch of like legal
battles of over the course of like two
years for that so sure they've been
trying not easy right but the point out
in the main game but the point is is
that you know that's it's separate
product that is you know more online or
MMO focus I mean into the same thing
with Elder Scrolls and you hope that you
know Elder Scrolls six is what we want
it to be in that you know they're also
gonna have the Elder Scrolls online
which is its own thing that kind of
please both people hopefully that
formula works I don't know how
successful yeah Elder Scrolls online has
been this the question is kind of you
know is it a zero-sum game yet as the
ascendance of all these co-op games
these online-only games these games that
are meant to be played pretty much with
people yeah
does that take a piece of the
development pie from these massive
single plurks experiences or does it
just just grow and continue to grow and
broaden there's one takeaway from I
don't think we always talk about this
right there's always different teams it
seems like right there's your
multiplayer team your single-player team
so I don't know how much it's taking
away the development as much as it's
taking away the money you know I mean
there are budgets in a reality that with
a business that is gaming instead of
have to have a second team it could have
been money that was funded over here to
make this work and make it go one of my
worries is that because this is
something we've seen across like so many
Ubisoft games and like this is a studio
that's spread across the world yeah that
like perhaps this was something that was
said from the high ups two years ago and
that their entire model has been based
around trying to learn you know then
hiring people who are like interests
like involved in that type of grading or
involved in our type of design like
we're talking about fallout like for me
the division looks like a really
interesting like modern fall at almost
you're like wandering around this world
like you know finding survivors like
running into
like individuals and and bandits and
whatnot I really want to play that game
on my own and like I think you're
terrifying about like you just being
forced into into doing it because the
funny thing about co-op is that like
often the games that like maybe are
quite boring our fun and co-op like I
spent most of well maybe that doesn't
count but I spent most of Christmas
playing UFC on the ps4 my brother drunk
because every game is fun when you're
playing with a beer like Borderlands 2
game I feel yeah exactly
I never never pay forward lands on my
own I mean the current example right is
destiny yeah everybody like in the
beginning destiny comes out numbers at
haha this story sucks and now you only
these people hooked on it and no one's
listening to what you're saying on what
the game saying on the raid right it's
like shoot that to that alright coated
and then use BS around your friends
while you run around and like that's
great that works that Borderlands that
works that's why I love it and that's
why I wasn't interested originally in
tales from the borderlands it came out
it's like a story based round Portland's
Mike I
I know handsome Jack's a bad guy like I
don't know the story of it but then when
you play it it's like oh this is amazing
this is a really funny story
it doesn't need me to know Borderlands
thank goodness because I don't know cuz
I run around play with my friends so I
guess we're gonna have to wait and see
and see if the division is something
you're gonna be forced to have to play
I'm so worried it's gonna be like the
crew but with third-person shooting
you